the modern city with all this humanity
technology and infrastructure crammed
into a small space it can be
overwhelming how do we navigate this
ever-changing world to make our cities
better simpler smarter that's what
Mouser and I wanted to find out to help
us explore where Humanity is heading and
the technology is driving us there we've
partnered with some like minds at Wired
brand lab I'm stopping by their office
to talk to Michael Copeland so Michael
I'm interested in finding out how
technology can be used to transform the
cities of the future but honestly I
don't know where to start
what are the biggest issues facing the
world today that technology could help
alleviate the fundamental things are
like transportation how I eat where's my
food coming from and where do I live so
shelter technology is taking on all
those things but now we're you have a
new technology and we have new answers
it starts with providing better
information if you think of a city or
the world as a big system how that
system works and then we can make better
decisions on build here don't build here
or here's what would happen if 10,000
more people moved into this neighborhood
here are the implications for all kinds
of things I think I've got a list of
issues that might be able to address but
I think will really help I have some
companies you should meet and it's gonna
take you a RIF of the world and I mean
that quite literally so I'm off with the
help of Mouser
and some of their leading suppliers like
analog devices Intel microchip
technology and molex I'm travelling the
world
exploring the ways people and companies
are using innovative technologies and
shaping Smarter Cities my first stop is
porto portugal where i'll take a closer
look at a company looking to turn every
vehicle on the road into a roving Wi-Fi
hotspot
[Music]
you